you have critics like Michael
schellenberger who I think makes a very
powerful case that we're not doing what
Portugal did and instead we have a
disaster unfolding that is likely to
blow back on those of us who want to see
the drug laws liberalize um Zach can we
run that clip I think you could get rid
of drug dealing or drug use without a
severe curtailment of our civil
liberties which nobody not even the most
fascist really in our society would
support but you can disallow open drug
scenes which is the the homeless
encampments you can disallow open-air
drug dealing it's hard but it is we do
know how to do it which is that you
basically suppress any
um you know you see one dealer and one
addict making a sale on the street
that's not a priority for police but
once it becomes known and part of the
problem is that like addicts if you live
in Cleveland like you know that San
Francisco is a place that you can go to
and use heroin openly and freely in a
low cost and so when you shut that
opener drugs seen down an open drug
dealing down it massively improves the
security of the neighborhoods
so this speaks to uh fear that I've seen
a lot even when we were mentioning we're
going to have this conversation it's
been expressed in the comments that if
you decriminalize all drugs in America
every city is going to turn into San
Francisco or Portland
um and there's going to be you know tent
cities everywhere so does that need to
be
part of the conversation with drug
decriminalization and how do you address
that well I mean yeah it was something
Michael schollenberg saying um you know
when it comes to the issue about the
open-air drug markets right that's one
conversation and then when it comes to
what do you do about all the people who
are using drugs and others and that's
where Michael is ultimately incredibly
disingenuous full of recommending
policies that are internally incoherent
and all this sort of stuff and playing
on people's fears around this stuff so I
think that when it comes to you know
increase like Michael's coming out
against say Michael schellenberger
became a leading opponent to Safe
injection sites right the supervised
consumptions that just seems the
opposite of what he's talking about
about public drug use what we know based
upon Decades of evidence from 60 cities
around the world throughout Europe now
Australia Canada Etc is that when you
open up a safe injection site or what's
now called an overdose prevention center
or supervised consumption room right
that basically which are essentially
needle exchange programs with a back
room and a nurse where people can't get
their drugs there but they can bring in
drugs they've obtained elsewhere and
then use them there what you find in the
evidence is first of all it eliminates
over those fatalities right there has
not been there have been I think tens or
hundreds of thousands of people who you
know have now around the world hadn't
suffered an overdose in one of these
facilities not one of whom has died
never mind the people who would have
died out on the streets right secondly
what it does is it enables people to
begin to improve their health right
there's a kind of quiet place where they
can be right where they're where they're
not on the streets right where they're
behind and they can get a cup of coffee
maybe wash their clothes maybe talk to a
counselor you know and have a safe place
to use their drug and then chill out
somewhere right thirdly the evidence
shows it's a significantly reduce the
public nuisance the open-air drug
problem you find fewer used syringes on
the streets when you have a safer
injection site you see less of that kind
of drug dealers because those
consumption sites have an incentive to
try to you know keep the people who come
to their facilities from being involved
in drug stuff on the streets right so
that though his opposition to supervise
consumption sites just as antithetical
to everything we're talking about
including what he and I and everybody
else agrees with which is that you can't
allow open-air drug markets now the
question about open-air drug markets
that's a different one you know and
that's something where I look for
example what happened another European
model they called it the Frankfurt model
beginning 30 years ago where they had a
major problems with open air drug
dealing and drug using in some of the
parks in Frankfurt and others and what
the mayor did was basically set up a
Monday morning group where she had to
head a police that had a prosecution the
head of Health Services the head of
Social Services that have Housing
Services and a few of the top people and
at that meeting it was like okay what's
the focus here and the police would say
well we're thinking of having a little
Crackdown in this neighborhood there you
know and then the Clinton mayor said
well so what are we going to do with the
people that you're picking up and then
it would be well can housing take them
can this take them it was a coordinated
policy of the source that for example
Temple mayor London breed in San
Francisco has totally abdicated has
totally failed right it's not nobody I
mean I was just in San Francisco last
week you look at the open air scenes
going on there and it's unsightly it's
problematic nobody wants to accept that
you look what happened in Europe and I
think somewhat has happened in New York
as well a lot of that remember New York
used to have big open-air drug markets
right part of what happened was a
policing strategy which pushed people
off the streets I mean a de facto policy
that said that if drug use or even
selling is happening behind closed doors
and we're not getting complaints it's
not open air it's not messing with a
sense of community security we're not
getting complaints from Neighbors then
that becomes a low priority for us the
key to dealing with open-air drug
markets is not getting rid of drug use
because you can't do that or you can
only try to reduce it through other
programs the key is pushing that stuff
indoors in ways that don't harm the rest
of the community right that's the in
Roger they called it the Rotterdam like
dealer program or something where the
the police knew that's what you had to
do right and then the other thing is is
distinguishing in policing among the
problematic people involved in dealing
and the less problematic or what I would
call the serious retain the
dealers and the non-asshold dealers if
somebody if you got a guy running a
local Bodega
and under the table they're selling a
little heroin or cocaine or whatever to
their local the same people you know
shop in their stores it's a kind of
under the table it's quiet they know
their customers they're not selling
their kids basically from a policing
perspective you want to basically turn a
blind eye to that stuff conversely if
somebody's out there on the streets and
they're Hawking this stuff or they're
they're harassing people walking by
they're making people feel unsafe or
they're selling the kids or things like
that that should be a number one
priority of the cops the cops should be
stopping those people they should be
arresting those people and if those
people don't want to take some service
except some kind of helping service then
those people need to be put off the
streets in a serious way
schellenberger's approach is idiotic
because he takes a real problem about
public drug use where we need real
solutions and then he does something
like opposing safe injection sites which
is the opposite of what you'd want to be
doing in order to deal with open-air
drug use when you look at say the way
Portugal the pioneered this policy
30-year 20 years ago the early 2000s you
know they didn't say let's set up the
treatment first person to do that they
do the two things simultaneously you
know you end the criminalization of
possession and you're changing the
systems approach as well right I mean so
you do both of those sorts of things
there's no place in America whether it's
Oregon and California or even wealthy
cities that have fully enough access to
treatment these things can be expensive
one thing about harm reduction is that
all you know people talk about we need
clinical treatment beds most people with
a drug problem don't need a treatment
bed and treatment quote-unquote beds are
expensive very very expensive you want
to reach people and and and and
hopefully you know be able to help them
thanks for watching that excerpt of a
live stream that Zach weismiller and I
did with Ethan nadelman late of the drug
policy Alliance about legalizing all
drugs if you want to watch another
excerpt go here if you want to watch the
full conversation go here and come back
next Thursday at 1 pm eastern time
because every week we've got a live
stream with another great guest that
you're going to be into thanks for
watching